a bit more with the sports writer
Natasha Henry who joins us from central
Anna to see Natasha good afternoon to
you it's a pretty familiar lament this
that the FA is a monolithic Victorian
era institution right for change yeah
there's a phrase that I often use which
is male Palance tell and I think that
very much sums up the people that govern
English football even when we look at
the five gentlemen that have signed the
letter they all fit that elderly white
male stereotype that they're actually
talking about if they can do the job why
is it a problem or are we saying they
can't do the job because they're white
and male and pale no one's saying they
can't do the job all we're saying is
that when you look at football on the
pitch in the stands it's so diverse
there's women there's people from all
different countries and nationalities so
why isn't the people that govern the
sport the same way in this letter to
Damian Collins that these five figures
have sent our quote for me that they
talk about the embarrassing failure of
our national team for the past 50 years
not obviously making a linkage between
this monolithic culture as they
described it and the failure of English
football I mean there are other people
who say actually how I mean if this is a
in global terms a relatively small by
population country we've done pretty
well actually in things like the World
Cup European Championships might not
feel that way but actually we
consistently box above our weight I mean
the structure of the Football
Association and the lack of success of
the national team are two very different
things one is about the way we train
young footballers about their education
about that gap between the ages of 16
and 21 where a lot of people fall out of
football and have no second career
choice no guidance but then we're
talking about the Football Association
which rules football in this country if
you have a hundred twenty-one people on
the FA Council and 115 of them all look
the same it's not likely you're going to
get any different answers to the
questions you ask just go back to the
letter that's been written to Damon
Collins the chair of the sport committee
there in the House code
one of the arguments is advanced is that
the FA needs to act effectively as a
counterweight to the to the EPL to the
English Premier League I mean again
there'll be some people looking at this
and thinking well you know the Premier
League has created the most successful
domestic league in perhaps in sporting
history if it ain't broke don't fix it
well it depends what you see as broken
and what you see is needing fixing
I do think a lot of the people at the
Football Association now weren't there
when the deal was done but Greg Dyke was
actually one of the people that was Pro
the Premier League so it's very
interesting to see him now come out and
say that they have too much power
I do feel there needs to be a separation
of interests in order to create a
football that is for everyone whether
that's on the picture off the pitch when
we look at the the organizations and
individuals that make up the FA I mean
you've got the counties represented
you've got Oxford and Cambridge you've
got the armed services in some
multitudes particular counties there
you've got one supporters group just one
supporters group and to two former
players how would you read jig that
balance I mean it's it's a very big job
for me to sit here and say I would do
this or do that but I do think we need
to look at it independently so maybe we
do need to bring people people from
outside the game maybe from other sports
so they understand the competition but
who who represent the players who
represent the fans who represent the
people that work at football clubs
because right now they don't at all yeah
I know you've been briefed on this or at
least are aware of another story that
concerns the FA that's that's proving
popular at least of interest today this
concerns primary school children girls
in particular as part of the FA reaching
out trying to get more girls play
football and it's been criticised has
been passion izing this this literature
is suggesting in football that the bibs
can be used for girls that quote smell
nice and the like what would you make of
this I think this this completely proves
our point of what we're discussing in
saying that the people running football
scenes have a lack of understanding of
those involved
I can't believe anyone thought that was
an acceptable letter and I have to give
the utmost respect to the young girls
that wrote back and and told him told
the Chairman that this is unacceptable
because I think that shows that they
know what they want to do they're lucky
they have great female footballers that
are role models and they know they don't
need to change anything in order for
them to play football
Natasha Henry thanks a lot thank you